hey everyone its Johanna here right the
dreaded saddlebag or outer thigh it's a
very common problem ever for women
especially if you're in your prime
remember we cannot spot reduce specific
area of our body so if you think that by
lying on your side and doing a hundreds
of leg lifts we'll get rid of saddlebags
it just won't happen if you want to get
rid of fat you need to stand up and move
as many muscles as possible and
challenge your body which is what
today's workout aim to do these four
exercises will target your upper thighs
and your hips in order to get rid of
saddlebags 45 seconds of workout with 15
seconds of rest per exercise so do your
5 to 10 minutes of warm up and let's
start the first workout it's going to be
crazy love with a hop and curtsy lunge
to your right so twist your body
slightly I'm going to set my timer and
let's start so remember as you hop I
want you to touch down ready let's go
Kristie lunch to your left
touch down hop and touch good there you
go
so it's working on your lower legs with
a little bit of cardio in between good
job there you get a hop as high as you
can and as you curtsy lunge really twist
and feel your ultimate working good job
keep going up lunch low good job the low
ego the more you feel your legs working
get very nice gentle lunch up hot lunch
down hop one last one don't hop and hop
good second workout it's
to be double side leg raise with 2
jumping jacks and to fight leg raises
ok let's start with our left leg good
double leg raises squeeze your outer
thighs - jumping jacks and right so lift
it up and feel your up spies working the
jumping jacks movement who also be
working on your outer thighs as you open
up your legs good keep going up squeeze
down tonight
there you go remember in order to get
rid of that we want to constantly be
moving squeeze it up good keep going up
squeeze very nice
can you feel your also nice one more
good
this little girl is a kickboxing spy
dream so stand with your left leg
forward right leg back I want you to
pivot your left leg and kick forward
duck and Street and kick all right let's
hear so drink duck switch kick with your
left leg duck
switch okay say magic then you want to
be kicking someone you're talking down
to protect yourself and you're switching
it's a really fun move to do switch kick
duck switch very nice good duck switch
so kick the person in front of you
doctor protect yourself and switch nice
dark switch give in your left leg duck
switch
take down switch one last cake
good job post-workout I want you to
stand left leg forward right leg back
bring your knees in
bring your back and kick with it use to
the side okay 30 seconds on your right
leg first let's go bring it up back kick
with your heel skin up kick with aliens
all these moves are all work even if
it's and your outer thighs and with a
little bit of balancing as well keep
going keep with it is gone all these
taking movements would really work on
your alpha and your inner thighs as well
hence that's kick change let's go bring
it up and kick with your heels so do you
really want to be kicking with your hips
kick in and kick let's go
cake up and kick bring us up and cake
let's go come on
okay I want to see those kicks okay up
and in cake last one and cake ah now
that was one set 45 seconds of rest to a
minute if you need to and what we want
to do is to repeat the entire circuit
again now that you know the moves I want
you to be able to do the moves without
much rest and there are a lot of key
things involved it's because kickboxing
is actually one of the best workout in
order to get rid of saddlebags because
it really works on your outer thigh and
your inner thigh see if you can
pick up kickboxing okay seven more
seconds and we're moving into the second
circuit with curtsy lunge let's go
curtsy lunge one hop lunch to your side
one hop good keep going
very nice up lunch through your outer
thighs working lunch low hop high and
lunch low only 45 seconds let's go
pump your heart rate up up good job
you're burning those unwanted alter nice
fat by doing jumping movements and side
curtsy lunges good keep going ah lunch
remember to your body
one last one jump rest for 15 seconds
second workout remember double side legs
race
jumping jacks and double types okay
so really adds a nice working and let's
go up to two jumping jacks ah - good
double jumping jacks up - I want you to
have fun when you're working out so all
these movements for me they are really
fun because they involve some kicking as
well hit keep going really bring your
leg up and feel your upper thighs
working good let's not stop right now
you're almost there come on keep going
one last one jumping jacks get
kickboxing inspired moves left leg
forward right leg back and imagine you
want to turn your body and kick your
opening which is right in front of you
I'm stopped ready and let's go kick
forward duck up stretch kick dark switch
very nice I want to see those high kicks
switch kick duck
and switch remember to turn your left
leg for a higher kick and switch
ah nice duck so kick your ponen protect
yourself and screech kick dark and
stretch nice
let's go through all suffice working
duck and switch let's go take heart duck
and switch very nice last one and switch
won't work out one day back bring your
knees in and kick with your heels to the
side okay so 30 seconds on each leg and
this is your last workout come on give
it your all
let's get up up and take for the hoos I
want to see those strong kicks if you
really want to get rid of this settle
that kick them off good kick
alright take very nice bring your knees
in as high as you can work in your hips
and work on those ticks to burn down on
your health and ice and we'll show your
inner thighs ah okay good change sign up
let's go up Kate very nice go come on if
you weren't strong in your right leg you
need to work on on your left leg as well
bring your arms up for the extra balance
and remember
- cake with the hills let's go nice ah
okay keep going
last one last one give me the strongest
kick again one more go very very good
job there are a lot of moves in this
workout in order to burn outer thigh fat
if you are a beginner do two sets if you
want to challenge yourself you can do
three or four sets do this workout two
to three times weekly for best results
and don't forget to do your regular
cardio and strength training as well as
to eat clean based on my own personal
experience and many more other feedbacks
kickboxing is actually one of the best
workout to work on your hips and your
thighs and also overall fitness so if
you can join a kickboxing class or you
can do this workout with me at home all
the best for new Fitness food and
motivational videos please like share
and subscribe to my youtube channel and
website do follow me on Facebook
Instagram and Twitter to stay connected
with me thanks guys